Let's get back to the phones at six one seven
eight three zero. Forty seven fifty.
You know who has not called in for ten months?
It's been 10 months since we caught him live.
It's furious. Trump's Jimmy from Philly. Let's
see what's going on with Jimmy.
Jimmy. It was September 24th, the last time
you called in. Are you in a welding facility?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. I got to shut the mouth off. What's
up?
Hey, Jimmy, please. Please don't scream into
the phone. It's very unpleasant.
Oh, I'm sure I am. I'm a real loud noise and
we get away.
Yeah, please. That nice. I like that. Nice,
quiet, calm Jimmy voice. The quieter, the
better.
Yeah. Yeah. The one you never hear. Right.
So. So David, I really don't have a question.
I have a statement about one this all around.
Survivor is concocted by the Chinese and the
Democrats to get rid of Trump. And Two Black
Lives Matter is a joke stolen. If you read
a website, they're based on Trayvon Martin,
the guy who attacked one or Jimmy Jimmy.
I want to hear. I don't want to hold on a
second.
I don't want to miss a second of what you're
saying. You're so loud. You've got to move
the phone like a foot from their mouth.
You've got to move it. Like, literally while
it is away.
It's kind of hard. I apologize. Yeah, I work
around machinery. I get loud, too.
So Black Lives Matter you don't like.
No, I don't like them because they're based
on a lie.
OK, what lies the.
Trayvon Martin. Attack attacked an armed man
and lost. And Michael Brown went for a cop's
gun and lost that one to.
And and so this relates to what? What do you
mean, what do you talk?
I don't know what you're talking about, you
so. So but so you don't like Black Lives Matter?
No, I think that's a big lie. I think. I think
anybody who demonstrates some kind of racial
pride is just showing their stupidity. Oh,
I feel like have to be white. I'm. I'm not.
OK. All right. And is black. I'm sure Yvonne
is looking for Jimmy.
Is Black Lives Matter a a racial pride group
or is it a racial equality.
I would say so, yes. Yes, I would say so.
I would think that if they were children of
protest, they are stupid. Is that why would
you bring a child with some different woman
violence?
I saw Brenda. I saw a bunch of kids with no
masks at the anti mask, anti lockdown protests
to.
Yeah, well, you know, it's funny how people
can go to church and I'm an atheist, but,
you know, Black Lives Matter and be out there
protesting.
No. But hold on a second, Jimi, because now
you're saying something different. You said
Black Lives Matter is bad because you saw
kids at the protests. But what about the kids
that the anti mass protests? Are you worried
about that? That.
No, you're not. And why not?
Nobody's happy when they see Black Lives Matter
come downstream. OK. You don't get a warm,
fuzzy feeling. Where did you get here?
Did you get a warm, fuzzy feeling from the
armed anti mask protesters intimidating law
enforcement?
I think it's still there. Sorry, what? I don't
see where they're going to be armed. Why not
just not wear the mask? But you know what?
They they have the right to be on. OK.
But so did you get it. But the question was,
did you get a warm, fuzzy feeling from it?
No. Absolutely. You did. OK. I went out with
a waste of my time like that. Jimmy, are you.
Are you in a riding mower right now? No.
No, I was. I stopped it. No, no. Looking at
me. Burstall. Wow. I had to walk away from
them.
All right, Jimmy. Very good. Well, it sounds
like everything. Are you off alcohol and on
LSD still or.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I actually stopped drinking.
Tremendous. I could take a beer. I can promise.
Yeah. Ridiculous. That is that isn't really
clear. I mean, but. Yeah. Right. What
do
you think we are, Charabanc David.
Sorry, I. Shadow band.
Oh yeah. Yeah.
What does that even your moderators do. Take
me off shadow. And what was one of them. Gay
when I make a gay joke about the politician.
All right, Jimmy, we're going to
let him go when Jimmy starts going homophobic.
We do. Let him go. Let's see who and what
a connection, huh?